the sigma Mill is a more internally
focused sibling to the alpha male while
the alpha male quantifies himself on his
high position and social hierarchy the
sigma refers to forego the social
hierarchy and need for external
validation altogether and pursue
internal strength instead essentially a
loner or a stray man although Sigma
males have had close Circles of friends
and loved ones with whom they should be
catch Sigma male is not socially inept
but simply socially disinterested
prefers solitary activities where you
don't have to play social politics you
can simply focus on himself specific
male accepts that he does not need power
over others as the alpha male desires
but rather needs only power to control
himself and preserve his own autonomy
from other single males are often
pragmatic but may be seen as others
aloof paranoid secretive or selfish